- So originally you were like
an athlete from Hong Kong?
- Yes, yes, yes.
- [Kelly] Like fencing, is that?
- Yeah, I was a fencer.
- Cool.
- That's cool.
- My parents, they were Olympians too.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- My dad was a fencer.
My mom's a gymnast.
- Wow.
So I guess it would've been a letdown
if you didn't do something
in that category.
- Yes.
I mean, I was prepping for
London Olympics back then,
and then I just, while prepping
I just told my parents,
"Hey, you know what?
I always had this dream about music.
Let me do my thing."
- How did that go over?
- I mean, they want me, of course,
to go to the Olympics,
you know, do my thing.
And you know, it took me
seven months to persuade them.
- Wow, but you were persistent.
That's a lot of months.
- Yeah, they were really against me.
And then they're like,
"You're outta your mind."
My principal told me that
this is the worst decision
you're gonna ever make in your life.
- [Kelly] Have you sent him a letter?
- No.
- I think he knows by now he was wrong.
- Or like a signed headshot.
Oh my God.
- Then after I debut as a singer
and I went back to have a
concert and I invited him.
And then he said, "Jackson,
we believed in you."
(everyone laughing)
We believed.
- This happens.
It happens.
That happened to me.
I was like, what?
I was like, people were totally like,
"That's never gonna happen.
Everybody has a dream."
Like, and then they were
like "The whole time,"
you'd see them on the news.
And they're like, "We
believed from the beginning."
And I'm like, you are a liar.
- We knew you were the one.
- Yeah, yeah.
So wait, so were your parents
worried about you guys
like in the entertainment industry?
Were they worried?
- Yeah, at first.
I said, "Hey, I passed
this audition in Korea.
I'm going, I'm leaving."
And then they're like, you know what?
They told me about this
like entertainment,
no, they're gonna kidnap you
and put you in a cave.
- Oh wait.
- Yeah, like parents.
- Yeah.
- And then they're like,
"No, you not gonna do that.
They're gonna, I'm not, we're
not gonna see you again.
You're gonna be MIA."
And I'm like, no, let me live my dream.
And yeah, seven months of persuading them
and they're supportive.
- That's amazing.
- Do we have to sit this far?
(woman laughing)
- You're just so cool
we're giving you room.
- We wanna adopt him.
(audience applauding)
- [Kelly] We were giving you room.
- Nobody's gonna kidnap you, son.
There's no caves for you.
You made it, kid.